I felt a marker should be put down to
say clearly to everybody that a female
Bishop is not found in the Bible a lot
of things which aren't found in the
Bible for example the Church of Ibelin
as we know it that came around over a
thousand years after the Bible was
written I beg to disagree the Church of
England legally begins with the arrival
of st. Augustine in 597 and that is in
all the law books I can assure you the
church was founded by our lord jesus
christ and god the father chose blessed
Mary to be the mother of his only son he
chose the time and the place so the
argument that God would have chosen a
different time in place and Jesus who
chose twelve men called apostles who
chose man male bishops and they chose
priests who were men would have been
choosing the women today is totally
wrong well we're talking about first
century Jew Dovan oh it's a very
different society to the society we know
today women's position in that society
was very different things have evolved
surely the church should evolve like
that well as John Betjeman said how odd
of God to choose the Jews but God the
Father bless him did choose and he chose
the time and the place
he chose Mary and Bethlehem he chose to
have a son as Paul says born of a woman
and the Lord Jesus Christ made a very
deliberate choice of those who were to
carry on his work we cannot turn round
and say fifty thousand years later when
things have changed dramatically again
that it is wrong
we had living lain there speaking out
and saying that she hopes she inspires
other women I'm actually this move her
promotion makes the church more
accessible and that can only be good
news in terms of increasing
congregations up and down the country I
have to differ largely on this one my
experience locally is that the lady who
ran a parish emptied it
the Archdeacon himself told me she left
eight people she went to another Church
and emptied it in 15 months
Libby i'ma show an anecdote though I
mean I'm not as a fact I'm short Libby
is wonderful I do not wish i L in any
shape or form but there's a little clue
in what she said she hopes to inspire
women a bishop is supposed to inspire
everybody men women and children it was
very telling that the servers were all
female that there was much parading
around outside the minster and comment
so you don't think in a very
male-dominated Church there should be
someone who does appeal to the female I
don't think the church is male-dominated
it is a mantra that people have used
until they've convinced themselves I was
a convent chaplain to some wonderful
Church of England nuns I have with me
today here in the studio
the lady who was my church warden for
many years who was a wonderful support
who visited anything her play should
only be supporting not to actually take
a lead role well you tell me why I can't
have a child
God created male and female and he
created woman and how wonderful you
you're gorgeous I'm not you can do
something
I can't God decided there was male and
female they have different things to do
in his design and we can't swap it over
the motherhood and priesthood are not
things that could be changed around well
I think that's a very specific example
but the Church of England says just
brief if you will that you're an
isolated voice no that is what the media
wish to say I have to change in England
statement
well the Church of England would say
that because it suits them to say it a
lot of people don't have a voice a lot
of ordinary people have walked out of
church because they're fed up with it
you can look at the figures for Scotland
you can look at the figure Wayne that's
all and female clergy
I don't blame it all on female clergy
they have not filled the churches that
is a fact okay we're going to have to
leave it there it's been fascinating
talking
thank you thank you so much for your
kindness